Working toward long term achievements can be mentally and
physically exhausting. It can be a
let down to work towards a goal and not see results as
quickly as you were hoping for. But if you work smart
achieving your goals is possible. No matter your goals,
here at psych2go we have 7 tips to help you achieve them.
One, write your goals down. Even if you
know what you want, actually writing down your goals has proven
to be more effective. Make sure that it's visible
so you have a continual reminder on what you've set out to achieve.
try putting a note on your bathroom mirror or your fridge
so you'll see it everyday.
Two, be patient with yourself.
Rome wasn't built in a day
and reaching your goals won't necessarily happen super fast.
It will likely take hours and hours of hard work.
The best things in life often take time and that makes them more rewarding
Three, make time in your week for goals.
Instead of trying to rush through your project, allow
yourself an hour a day or a day a week to work on small
sub-goals that will contribute to your overall vision.
Doing things weekly in small segments will help prevent
you from feeling stuck or frustrated in your attempt to achieve your goal
Four, celebrate your acheivements no matter how small.
Sometimes if can feel like you're so far from reaching a milestone
and you're more only closer than where you started
But if you're actively working towards something, that's not true.
Remember that these goals are called long term for a reason.
Find a way to reward yourself with a favourite snack or
activity when you finish a part of your goal.
Five, remember that roadblocks aren't failures.
We all know the phrase 'when one door closes, another one opens'.
Well, it's not just inspiring, it's factual.
Sometimes life has a different plan for how we achieve our goals.
So next time you hit a wall, remember to be kind to yourself.
You never know what could be around the corner.
Six, listen to criticism and do not take it personally.
Criticisms are not personal attacks on your work.
They aren't a chance for you to get defensive and possessive of your work and goals.
Instead, take the criticism and use it to refine and improve upon your goal
and the methods of getting there.
Critisism allows us to double check our work with new eyes
and create something even more amazing.
Seven, work with like minded people.
This is an especially important tip
because it's easy for you to feel like you're alone in your endeavours.
There's also other times where you'll feel stuck in your efforts to
figure out solutions to the hurdles that sit between you and your achievements.
Talking and collaborating with those who share similar goals
is actually a great way to see things in a different way,
getting inspired and maintain drive.
Climbing the mountain of success
is always easier when you're working as a team.
Hey everybody! I just want to give a personal thank you video for
you guys for always supporting psych2go and making this all possible for us.
Our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible
so that it promotes self awareness and it helps you guys grow.
However we want to make more content for you guys
and would love your support in buying one of these bracelets
from our partner introvert palace.
Check out the bracelet it's pretty cool and it even includes Pluto.
The link to purchase will all be in the description below and I hope you guys have an amazing day. Bye!